quel plaisir d'être avec vous
plaisir pour partager des émotions et
partager une conviction forte que j'ai
on va passer quelques minutes ensemble
alors prenez le temps de bien vous
installer dans vos fauteuils
confortablement
je suppose que vous m'entendez bien
clairement haut et fort
et je pense que vous me voyez aussi dans
le feu des projecteurs
ça tombe bien parce que moi je vous vois
pas
je vous vois pas pas parce que j'ai la
lumière des projecteurs dans les yeux
c'est parce que je suis déficient visuel
mais je vais me représenter je m'appelle
Eric Payan vous l'avez entendu j'ai 58
ans je sais je les fais pas
je suis un jeune retraité depuis
quelques semaines
et je suis un ex cadre supérieur de
l'industrie et je suis un jeune
entrepreneur puisque j'ai décidé que ma
retraite devait être active
à 18 ans j'ai eu les premiers troubles
visuels le diagnostic est tombé
maladie dégénérative de la rétine
à 25 ans
je n'avais plus que un dixième d'acuité
visuelle
c'est pas beaucoup
et à 25 ans démarrait dans la vie active
dans la vie professionnelle dans la vie
de citoyens dans la vie de jeune homme
dans sa vie affective dans sa vie
personnelle honnêtement c'est pas un
cadeau
c'est difficile
à 25 ans j'ai été obligé d'arrêter de
conduire
terrible
et depuis maintenant j'ai 40 ans plus
tard à 58 ans
on acquitté visuel
pas les proches de
pas grand chose
et finalement cette fragilité
il a fallu que j'en fasse quelque chose
il a fallu que je m'adapte et que je
m'adapte constamment sur ces 40
dernières années et puis j'espère 42
plus tant qu'à faire
il faut que je m'adapte parce que la
jungle dans laquelle j'évolue elle est
difficile elle est complexe laissez-moi
vous raconter une anecdote
il y a quelques années quand j'étais en
activité je me déplaçais régulièrement
en France et à l'étranger
nous habitons Paris à l'époque et
j'avais pris un taxi pour aller à
l'aéroport Charles de Gaulle je devais
aller à Toulouse
le taxi arrive à l'heure j'avais pris
beaucoup de marge pour arriver très en
avance à l'aéroport
le taxi me dépose au terminal je rentre
dans la dans le terminal la première
chose que l'on fait c'est se diriger
vers les écrans
et
regardez les vols en partance les vols
les plus loin de votre départ sont dans
le l'écran qui est le plus bas et là je
vois des destinations qui correspondent
rien à là où je devais aller
première décharge d'adrénaline
vendre panique je suis où
et je me rends compte au bout de
quelques minutes que je suis au terminal
B
et qu'en fait mon terminal c'était le D
le taxi s'est étoilé donc là j'ai
dépassé j'ai gagné le record du monde du
400 mètres ce que j'ai couru pour
atteindre le terminal d parce que c'est
franchement pas à côté à Charles de
Gaulle
et j'ai finalement trouvé le terminal D
et là je me suis dit mais comment
dois-je faire pour trouver la porte
d'embarquement de mon avion
vous savez ce que j'ai fait je me suis
mis à côté d'un poteau il y a toutes les
télévisions où il y a tous les vols
d'annoncés et puis plus le vol est
proche de son départ plus évidemment
c'est très intelligent c'est la télé qui
est la plus haute donc brouillard pour
moi
je me suis dit mais il y a bien des gens
qui vont prendre le même avion que moi
alors j'ai attendu
ça n'a pas loupé au bout de quelques
minutes un groupe de trois personnes est
arrivé ils ont regardé l'écran ils ont
dit Oh Toulouse c'est la porte 35 je me
suis dit cool je vais les suivre je les
ai pas lâchés d'une semaine
ils sont allés aux toilettes
ouais bah moi aussi je les ai suivis ils
ont pris l'avion j'ai pris l'avion je
suis arrivé à bonne destination c'est ça
ma jungle
donc il est facile de dire maintenant
avec cette fragilité que ma jungle elle
commence là à 10 cm
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
que fait-on de nos fragilités maintenant
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait avec cette
fragilité mais on peut élargir en disant
mais qu'est-ce que nous pouvons faire
avec nos fragilités nous avons tous des
fragilités
la première question on peut se dire
mais est-ce que je peux devenir le roi
de la jungle le roi ou la reine comment
puis-je faire pour
naviguer dans cette jungle qui est si
hostile
au passage un aéroport ou une gare pour
un malvoyant c'est un enfer
et pourtant il faut bien y arriver à
prendre son train et son avion
et la première règle et c'est clé là que
je veux partager avec vous c'est ces
clés qui m'ont permis d'arriver là où je
suis aujourd'hui de pouvoir parler
devant vous
c'est que j'ai refusé
d'être une victime
c'est fondamental
c'est le fondement d'un nouveau départ
si je suis resté je reste une victime je
n'accepte pas ma fragilité et finalement
la jungle elle m'engloutit et je ne fais
rien j'attends tout qu'on me donne tout
j'attends la compassion j'attends la
pitié c'est pas une vie d'homme
c'est pas une vie de femme au sens
générique
je refuse d'être une victime je
n'accepte pas d'être une victime
c'est insupportable
et ce fondement là est-il nécessaire oui
pour aller plus loin oui est-il
suffisant et ben non parce que la
deuxième étape une fois qu'on a décidé
qu'on ne serait plus une victime
bah il faut se mettre en action il faut
y aller
il faut la grimper la butte
alors est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'il y a
des moyens que l'on peut mettre en
oeuvre pour aller plus loin et dépasser
ce stade-là et de dire mais fragilités
je vais en faire une force mais je vais
vous livrer quelques clés que j'ai
utilisées et que vous pourriez utiliser
aussi parce qu'elles sont pas propres
elles sont en vous ces clés là
alors je vais vous parler des limites on
a tous et toutes des limites celle que
nous nous sommes fixées nous-mêmes
nous nous fixons notre cadre dans lequel
nous évoluons
mais finalement ces limites que l'on
peut dire présumée c'est celle que j'ai
décidé de me mettre
mais en réalité
l'action de dire je ne suis plus une
victime c'est d'aller vers des limites
dépassées je cherche toujours à dépasser
mes limites quand j'ai cherché cet avion
pour aller à Toulouse j'ai dépassé mes
limites j'ai battu le 400 mètres le
record du 400 mètres non c'est une
blague
mais n'empêche que j'ai atteint mon
avion potentiellement j'avais zéro
chance d'y arriver je l'ai eu mon avion
j'ai mis en place des stratégies pour y
arriver
elle c'est qu'une anecdote parmi tant
d'autres donc de ma limite présumée je
décide que je peux aller la dépasser
et je me fixe un objectif pour aller
dépasser mes limites
et cette nouvelle limite que j'atteins
cette limite dépassée à son tour une
fois qu'elle est dépassée elle devient
une nouvelle limite présumée et je peux
aller chercher un nouvel objectif pour
dépasser cette limite et ainsi de suite
vous comprenez la spirale positive la
spirale qui tire vers le haut qui vous
met en action qui vous mobilise
quels sont les leviers pour passer de la
limite présumée à la limite dépassée il
y a le levier de la survie
il y a le levier de la motivation
faut être sacrément motivé pour aller
prendre un avion quand on est malvoyant
et il y a le levier de l'estime de soi
quand on atteint un objectif ambitieux
et qu'on le réussit
quel gratification on en a
quelle on renforce son estime de soi et
on a de plus en plus confiance en soi
quelle récompense on obtient
on s'autorise on s'envoie des cookies
tout seul c'est super
et puis ça nourrit l'ambition puisque
sans ambition
il n'y a pas de moteur alors voilà ces
quelques clés que je voulais vous
présenter mais c'est pas encore
suffisant
on peut se poser la question finalement
mais
est-ce que nous sommes des vainqueurs
est-ce que nous avons en nous ce
potentiel pour dépasser ses limites
constamment
moi je connais la réponse c'est oui
et vous avez la même réponse en vous je
vais vous le montrer
j'aime partager cette phrase de cette
citation de Mark Twain il ne savait pas
que c'était impossible ils l'ont fait
ça bouge ça
imaginez cette photo
vous tout et tout ce qui est dans cette
salle vous avez été des vainqueurs
et parmi des centaines de millions c'est
pas un petit concours
c'est une grosse bagarre
c'est la jungle
et vous êtes sortis unique de cette
jungle vous êtes des vainqueurs si vous
êtes là
vous rendez compte vous avez la graine
de vainqueur en vous
à utiliser la
un deuxième exemple que j'aime partager
on a tous été ce bébé un jour
quand il apprend à marcher est-ce que ce
bébé il s'est dit ouais la marche c'est
galère ah non c'est trop dur je vais pas
le faire non ça me gonfle c'est pas
possible il se pose même pas cette
question
il se lève il tombe il se lève il tombe
il se lève il tombe et alors ça fait
partie son apprentissage est-ce qu'il se
pose la question de dire ah c'est trop
dur je vais pas y arriver
c'est pas une victime
c'est inscrit qu'il veut marcher quelles
sont les effets de levier qui
l'utilisent pour marcher
la fierté de voir la fierté de ses
parents dans les yeux de ses parents de
voir ses parents qui l'encouragent allez
allez mon petit vas-y
ce bébé ça a été vous ça a été moi
on a mis en œuvre une énergie incroyable
pour pouvoir se tenir debout aujourd'hui
c'est énorme non
alors vous êtes vraiment et nous sommes
tous des vainqueurs
il faut en être convaincus de ça et
c'est ma conviction
j'espère que ça sera la vôtre aussi
et puis il y a une autre
chose que l'on peut mettre en œuvre
c'est l'exercice de notre talent
soyez en convaincus nous avons tous des
talents
cette citation de Jules Renard le talent
exécute je reste juste sur cette
dernière phrase le talent exécute
autrement dit le talent sans le travail
c'est stérile
si vous n'utilisez pas vos talents c'est
dommage parce que vous perdez quelque
chose parce que vous passez au travers
de quelque chose
mais savoir qu'on a un talent et ne pas
le travailler ne pas le mettre en oeuvre
quelle tristesse mais quelle tristesse
quel gâchis
terrible
et quand le talent on arrive à le
mettre en œuvre avec d'autres qui ont
d'autres talents
et lorsque ces talents se complètent
on peut arriver à faire des choses ça
dégage une énergie incroyable
on augmente encore l'estime de soi parce
qu'on est plus fort parce qu'on arrive à
dépasser nos limites
parce qu'on est fier
et c'est tellement important d'être dans
cette pensée positive
mobiliser vos talents
utilisez-les trouvez-les utiliser les
et votre vie changera
une dernière citation que je voulais
partager avec vous de Georges Clémenceau
la seule façon d'échouer
c'est d'abandonner avant de réussir
j'aime cette phrase parce qu'elle me
convient bien
j'ai jamais rien lâché j'ai pas tout
réussi j'ai eu des échecs certes c'est
pas un problème l'échec
je me suis relevé j'ai recommencé j'ai
eu d'autres échecs des fois j'ai réussi
des fois j'ai pas réussi c'est pas grave
il y a quelques années de toute mon
expérience à la fois professionnelle et
mon expérience d'homme
vivant avec un handicap depuis de
longues années j'ai décidé avec une amie
on a coécrit un livre
pour témoigner de tout ce que j'avais
fait
parce que j'avais plaisir à partager ça
et puis plus récemment on l'a dit j'ai
créé une entreprise
dans la finalité et de sensibiliser les
chefs d'entreprise et leur chaîne
managériale
à l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap je devrais dire en situation de
fragilité
et même j'ai plaisir à dire comme nos
cousins québécois
des personnes extraordinaires
ça c'est la finalité
pour terminer
on ne vous êtes d'accord avec moi que ma
jungle a été franchement épaisse au
départ
tellement épaisses tellement sombre
tellement inextricable
que j'aurais pu m'y perdre
que j'aurais pu dire ma fragilité c'est
je peux pas je vais pas y arriver
ça va être terrible je vais subir mais
je l'accepte
bien non
j'ai décidé une fois pour toute que ma
fragilité allait devenir une force
et de cette force j'ai transformé ma
jungle en jardin
et dans mon jardin il y a des arbres
avec des fruits qui ont porté du fruit
et toutes les graines qu'il a fallu pour
construire ce jardin
en fait vous les avez aussi ces graines
là vous pouvez faire de votre jungle un
jardin
parce que vous avez tout ce qui vous
faut
il suffit de le mobiliser
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]